[Musique]
m
voir l'intérieur du corps en temps réel
y percevoir toute l'activité cellulaire
l'imagerie médicale à révolutionner le
diagnostic du cancer
un point de vue inédit rendue possible
grâce à radiotraceurs le fdg
ce produit a vu le jour il ya 45 ans
c'était en 1975
un groupe de scientifiques parvient à
synthétiser le 18f fdg un sucre
radioactifs une fois injectées dans les
veines
il permettra de dévoiler l'intérieur du
corps quelques mois après cet exploit à
l'été 1976 deux volontaires acceptent de
recevoir une dose on note aucun effet
secondaire le fluoro des oxydes du cause
le fdg est une molécule utilisée comme
radiotraceurs c'est un sucre semblable
au glucose qu'on a rendu radioactifs en
le combinant avec un atome de fluor 18
d'où son aspect fleurs et ça à l'écran
des cellules cancéreuses consomment
beaucoup plus du cause que les cellules
saines
le fdg se fixe au tissu qui consomment
beaucoup de blick aux six normales
tissus malades
la différence est dette
en entrant dans la cellule cancéreuse
la molécule de fdg subi une
transformation chimique qu'il empêche
d'en ressortir la masse cancéreuse
devient aussitôt radioactives
son rayonnement est ensuite capté par le
tep
l'appareil d'imagerie moléculaire et
retranscrit en images 3d en douze heures
la quasi-totalité de la radioactivité a
disparu du gore
[Musique]
si le produit n'est plus le diagnostic
lui prend forme de nombreuses vies sont
ainsi sauvés